very warm welcome to the program India's
top Court has postponed hearings on a
new citizenship law that's provoked
protests and violence nationwide the
judge's decision brought more
demonstrations in New Delhi they want
more details about the legislation from
the government before considering a
petition that won't happen until January
although I'll makes it easier for people
from Afghanistan Bangladesh and Pakistan
to gain citizenship but it excludes
Muslims critics say that's blatant
discrimination by a government they
accused of driving a Hindu nationalist
agenda well four people have been killed
in demonstrations since the law was
introduced but Prime Minister Narendra
Modi is refusing to back down
well Supriya Sharma is executive editor
of school dot in an independent news
website and she joins us on skype from
Mumbai Supriya very warm welcome to the
program the government claims that this
amended law only concerns undocumented
migrants and Indian Muslims he keeps
repeating have nothing to worry about so
why is this interpretation out there
that's fueling this violence and can
concern well it's unique concerns
because the changes in India's
citizenship law come at a time when the
government has announced plans to
prepare unnatural registered citizens
essentially the government wants to
screen all Indian citizens of French
and it could ask people to produce
documents to vote for their citizenship
and those who are unable to do so could
be declared undocumented migrants given
the recent changes in the law there he
was that this could leave Indian Muslims
uniquely vulnerable because members of
other religious communities could still
have the option of citizenship by
naturalization which is now being denied
to Muslims and it is this combination of
the changes in the citizenship law
alongside the government's announcement
of a national register of citizens
that's actually fueling intense anxiety
among Indian Muslims it's also important
to remember that Indian Muslims have
been feeling politically marginalized
over the last few years under Hindu
nationalist government where
heat crimes against them have been on
the rise the ruling party politicians
that we made making divisive comments
and so many believe that what we're
actually now seeing is a lot of pent-up
frustration which is coming to the fore
in the context of this citizenship law
Supriya Sharma what's your view of the
response that we've seen from the course
so far well there as many as 59
petitions filed in the Supreme Court
challenging the citizenship law but
those who were expecting that the courts
would step in and intervene are
disappointed because as we know the
fortress that's basically said it won't
stay the law in egt and it has push this
back to January where it where when the
next hearing would take place this is
clearly bound to leave a lot of people
disappointed we were hoping that the
Supreme Court of India would stand up
for the basic principle that underlying
the Indian Constitution secularism and
equality towards all being one of them
and is another fear perhaps Supriya not
just that people are disappointed but
that violence may continue and there's
no sign of these protests dying down
absolutely in fact what we're seeing is
that the protests are now spreading the
protest first began in India's northeast
where local communities fear that they
could get swamped by migrants from
Bangladesh we saw intense protests in
the state of exam which led to police
firing which left five people dead
from there the protests have spread
we're now seeing people in Tamil Nadu in
South India where there's a large
population of refugees who fled violence
in Sri Lanka now asking why have we been
kept out of this law and most
significantly protests are spreading
across Indian campuses we've lost
counted as many as 60 universities and
colleges have staged demonstrations and
more demonstrations are being announced
it's a Prius charmer their executive
editor of school Dotson thanks very much
for joining us on the program